los precios en el Reino Unido están
subiendo más rápido que en cualquier
otro país europeo y en Estados Unidos
dejando a muchos británicos preocupados
de Cara a los próximos meses la tasa de
inflación alcanzó en julio un nuevo
récord en 40 años con un 10.1%
interanual impulsado por el aumento del
coste de la energía serán seis meses
interesantes por delante agravados por
el hecho de que tenemos una sequía que
afectará el rendimiento de los cultivos
en el futuro la guerra en Ucrania no
está ayudando Así que hay una vorágine
de diferentes presiones el Primer
Ministro Boris Johnson debe dejar el
cargo el próximo mes y dice que
cualquier nueva medida quedará en manos
de su sucesor
preparamos todas las opciones listas
para que el Primer Ministro entrante el
5 de septiembre comienza a trabajar con
lo que más podemos hacer ya sean en los
impuestos verdes que debemos eliminar
para ayudar con estas facturas de
energía reduciendo impuestos
Pero según los economistas el peor está
por venir el banco de Inglaterra dice
que es probable que al aumento de los
precios del gas natural lleve la
inflación de los presos al consumidor al
13.3% en Octubre y que empujará a Reino
Unido a una recesión que podría
prolongarse hasta 2023